China caught red-handed lying about its
giant spy balloon hovering over America
it was last spotted this morning in
northeast Kansas and that's after it was
seen loitering in Montana which is home
to our nuclear silos and
intercontinental ballistic missiles
Beijing claims it is a civilian aircraft
used for meteorological research that
got knocked off course by bad weather
but the Pentagon says that's a bunch of
BS
we know this is a Chinese balloon and
that it has the ability to maneuver the
balloon has changed its course which is
again why we're monitoring it the
balloon continues to move Eastward and
is currently over the center of the
continental United States again we
currently assess that the balloon does
not present a military or physical
threat to people on the ground at this
time and we'll continue to review excuse
me continue to Monitor and review
options we assess that it'll probably be
over the United States for a few few
days
so why the hell hasn't Joe Biden shot
this thing down yet defense officials
have advised the president not to take
it out fearing it could cause cause
debris to fall and put People In Harm's
Way
any potential debris field would be
significant and potentially cause
civilian injuries or deaths or
significant property damage so again
this is part of the calculus in terms of
our overall assessment but again we'll
continue to monitor it we'll continue to
review our options and keep you updated
as able but Republicans say Biden looks
weak with each second he keeps his
communist balloon in the air
communists
we ought to bring this darn thing down
we have the capabilities and tools to do
that I'm confident that we we could have
done so safely I think we probably still
can do so safely they could have shot
that balloon down and the biggest risk
might have been hitting a cow a prairie
dog or an antelope this is a Brazen act
and so at the political level we have to
push back we have to defend American
sovereignty and we have to make clear to
the Chinese that we're not going to
tolerate this they're overflying our
nuclear sites and they keep getting away
with it because we let them there's no
consequences there's lots of questions
but the commander-in-chief is awfully
quiet
[Applause]
folks we're going to get to work thank
you for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
well that last question what is your
message to China I guess uh Harold is
that uh we're going to stop Anthony
blinken from going over there but the
but the real question is do we know how
long that balloon has been here and what
I mean the way I see it it looks like
somebody read someone was on a
commercial plane and noticed it first
but now we hear that it's been there
since Tuesday uh and today's Friday why
would they allow this thing to stay
there I don't know the answer to that
and uh there are more questions uh judge
and I think you've raised some of them
and we'll raise some of them around the
table I think for me and again it's good
to be back around the table a bit away
for a few days the uh for me that I was
curious and secretary Billington whom I
respect and like and know said that when
we detected the balloon we at that point
uh prevented it from being able to take
pictures and collect information I would
have two questions one when did we
detect it uh and two do we believe it
actually was collecting information
before it was the detected two I think
the president it would behoove the
president to to brief Congressional
leaders Democrat Republican alike and it
would behooves someone uh perhaps a
secretary of defense or the Secretary of
State or both or even the president to
give a briefing about this to give to
give some comfort and confidence that uh
what we can all assume and give the
benefit the doubt that it's being
handled but I think it's important they
do that the notion of it being shot down
I think is something that will only that
that talk will only increase if we don't
get some some information as the
American people those of us in the Press
those who are concerned about this about
why they're not doing that I thought the
Brigadier General was fine but we need
we need something more comprehensive I
think to to give people a sense because
at the heart of this if we don't send a
strong message to China
uh and in a relationship where mutual
interest are the centerpiece of a
relationship with behavior like this you
violate that relationship uh and I think
Democrats Republicans put that aside
Americans uh want to know what this
balloon is doing how long it's been
there and if it cause or has caused any
harm to our national security these are
all legitimate questions those are the
questions so I'll go to you Martha my
sources tell me that this balloon they
can they can essentially uh assess the
trajectory they can study the currents
there's a way to take it down it doesn't
have to be shot down they can take it
down as long as it's over an area where
you know there's not going to be like
Los Angeles or New York City major
catastrophe they haven't done that how
are we so sure of what this balloon is
doing especially since it is over seeing
areas that are where our nuclear sites
are well it's been across a couple of
areas that it should have been pretty
easy to do that over Alaska apparently
currently for quite a while then over
Montana and you saw I had a conversation
earlier with Senator Steve daines he
said you know that's why we call this
Big Sky country right we have plenty of
open space in Montana you know when the
people who live in the state want it to
be shot down over their state
um I think that's something that we need
to think about I also think that what
would have you know for a lot of people
who feel very uncomfortable about this
the greatest thing you could have heard
from the president would be an early
morning announcement you know last night
at uh or early this morning at 4 20 we
disabled this Invader Chinese spy
balloon because this Pentagon from their
own lips said this is a surveillance
vehicle a surveillance balloon and we
took it down we took it down safely we
have the technology to do exactly that
we're examining it we're taking a look
at what's on here and if it's innocuous
we can return it and the equipment to
the Chinese government and make sure
that this never happens again because if
it it ever does we will be doing the
same thing again because what we heard
also this afternoon from I was watching
generals to read us and he said expect
more of these expect more balloons to
cross over the country gathering
information about our silos that keep
our intercontinental ballistic missiles
so I mean it's a you know the message I
think that a lot of Americans are going
to take right now is that you know the
southern border is open right and the
skies above America are open so I'm not
quite sure where people feel like uh we
have real sovereignty in this country at
this moment based on just the facts on
the ground you know Jesse I mean that
they are over areas where uh you know
that are very significant they've got a
front row view to those areas China is
buying land in some of these areas not
far from these areas China's and the
universities
um you know China is not cooperating
with us about Wuhan and we're just
letting them fly a balloon over our
nation I mean is this a literal trial
blue to see what we would do if
something real happened pop it pop it
Bust It Up do whatever you need to do to
it imagine you had a neighbor you hated
who tried to sleep with your wife stole
all your Amazon boxes and killed your
grandmother with a virus and then
floated a little drone over your
backyard you're just gonna sit there and
watch this thing and say you know what
it's just a weather balloon we're
monitoring it no you're gonna shoot that
thing out of the sky
why not shoot it over Montana right it
hits a barn let's say it hits
Fred's Barn
Fred's famous in Montana there's two
people that live in Montana that is your
bomb Barn that it lands on the feds
reimburse you the money and then you set
up a little museum for the rest of your
life and live off that you do Good
Morning America you do fox and friends
that's it Canada is supposed to be an
ally judge they're just going to watch
what is he looking at the truckers
keep your eyes open Trudeau you're
supposed to be our boy you're just going
to let the balloon float by Biden the
commander-in-chief was overruled by the
generals if you're the
commander-in-chief and you say shoot
down the balloon and they say Mr
President go sit down and have a snack
that's not normal you shoot that down I
don't care what the generals say knock
it out also once you knock it out you
can collect all the Intel we don't know
what it is Judge how do we know it's not
pushing spores how about coven 22 23
whatever year it is we have no idea what
this thing is bring it down before it
gets to New Jersey because I'm about to
lick one off
well you know you know Greg in 2001
there was a problem between the United
States and China we had a a a a flight
that was they said in their airspace we
said it wasn't we're forced to land uh
and they took that plane and they
studied that plane for the intelligence
they kept our people there for 11 days
and the turnabout on our side is like
hey no problem they're collecting stuff
on on the weather I think the bright
side in all of this is at least we know
the balloon was made in China because it
could be really really worse I heard Joe
Biden just announced that we will be
shooting it but in the leg
uh has anybody considered steering it
towards the Space Needle seems to me
that's the thing I would do rather than
shoot it you know and and it could also
be Fang Fang you never know Valentine's
Day is coming up this was going to be a
little surprise but you know here's the
thing
a little surprise for swallow well
anyway uh how dare we question or
speculate on the origins of this Chinese
balloon how dare we if we can't bring up
the origins of kobit because that was
considered racist how is that not racist
the origin of the balloon you know why
should you be allowed to do that why is
it any different and about what about
that point that the Chinese keep saying
about everything everything's unintended
this was unintended uh the fentanyl
poisonings unintended obviously covid
unintended uh the Spy balloon unintended
I'm beginning to think they're not
intending they're not tending to a lot
of things everything's an accident
between their badly made Goods covered
fence and all new spy balloons beginning
to think maybe LeBron James should
question their brown nosing allegiances
let's send them our own bad stuff what
is mom jeans coconut water boy bands
that's good
lastly in a serious note how is it that
the bidens treat a spy balloon from our
most potent adversary
far better than the Trump supporters you
know too bad they weren't this gun shy
with Ashley Babbitt
they might shoot a balloon down if they
find a red hat in it oh well said well
said man I'm not sure this would have
happened under a different president hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else